no
[Música]
hola soy vicente salvarse y soy el
fundador y se llevó de yo mí pero
también soy uno de los cuatro millones
de venezolanos que en algún momento se
fueron del país y que inevitablemente
sigue en contacto con el contexto social
desde la universidad y pasando por
startups como way fair grounds bousmail
aprendí cómo crear empresas desde cero
aprendí cómo hacer estrategias de
marketing y mercadeo impresionantes cómo
medir el impacto de esas estrategias de
mercadeo cómo medir la retención de un
usuario y aumentarla
como adquirir usuarios a una velocidad
mucho mayor de la normal digamos todas
las cosas que en teoría harían que un
negocio tecnológico sea exitoso lo que
sea que eso signifique pero no me di
cuenta que lo más importante lo iba a
aprender en venezuela en donde crecí en
caracas que es que dar valor
genera valor y de eso les quiero hablar
hoy
en el 2017 regrese a caracas a pasar mi
cumpleaños extrañaba muchísimo a mi
familia quería ver a todo el mundo y si
somos honestos quería comer unas buenas
arepas que tenía tiempo que no lo hacía
en caracas me encontré a todo el mundo
en mi reunión de cumpleaños en mi casa
estaba mi mamá mi papá obviamente
estaban mis abuelos estaban mis tíos y
me encontré a mi primo que
me enteré acaba de perder su trabajo y
en privado
me dijo muchísimas frases negativas y lo
vi con una gran tristeza en sus ojos con
la situación me dijo que se sentía
atrapado que no sabía qué iba a hacer en
todo el próximo año y después no sabía
si su carrera ser bien venezuela si
realmente podía vivir con el dinero que
iba a hacer de su carrera no se quería
ir de venezuela porque era su país pero
pero se sentía atrapado y el no tener
una rutina lo hacía sentir que todo
estaba amplificado todo esto tenía que
ver intrínsecamente con el contexto
macroeconómico y social del país y me
dijo esta frase que recuerdo muchísimo
en el camino recorrido que probablemente
todos hemos escuchado un montón en
venezuela- todo es cuesta arriba
después de que regresamos a la
conversación grupal quería hacer algo y
para mi familia y quería pedirles un
delivery de comida para la casa y
pregunté que dónde lo podía hacer si lo
podía hacer en una página web o en
alguna aplicación y todo el mundo se rió
y me empezaron a chalequear que eso que
eso no existía en venezuela y que bueno
que lo que podías hacer era ir a una
página en instagram de un comercio darle
click al link en la biografía que te
abría una conversación de whatsapp te
mandaba en el menú tenías una
conversación y bueno te mandaba en la
comida y él me dio el chalequeo mi primo
me dice bueno primo pero yo yo busco la
comida eso sí me da cinco dólares a
cambio y yo le traigo todo a todo el
mundo
y yo me reí dije bueno está bien si
busque la comida de 25 dólares fue
curioso porque realmente en ese momento
y desde que negociamos los cinco dólares
hasta que
trajo la comida y todo el mundo celebró
que la comida llegó a la casa y él la
entregó con una sonrisa
claramente sus ojos cambiaron se sentía
valioso había un cambio de actitud y me
senté a hablar en serio con mi familia y
como esto no existía como como no
existía una aplicación de verdad de
delivery de comida en venezuela más allá
de eso no existía comercio online no
existía un lugar para ir a comprar ropa
no existía un lugar en el que podía
comprar unos chocolates para mandárselo
a mi abuela estando en caracas o estando
fuera no había una manera de comprar un
cable nuevo para cargar el teléfono
tenías que ir al lugar y tampoco
evidentemente había uber no había una
manera de transportarte si no fuera
digamos lo más parecido era un taxi pero
todo el mundo me interrumpió a decirme
es que obviamente eso no se puede en
venezuela- que obviamente las cosas
habían empeorado y que sencillamente era
impensable que tú podías bajar a recoger
comida de un repartidor que es una
persona totalmente desconocida qué pasó
si esa persona sea algo que pasa si esa
persona me roba qué pasa ahora que esa
persona sabe mi nombre y donde yo vivo
hablamos incluso de como huber
según mi familia no podía existir en
venezuela y el sistema de raid schering
que estaba ocurriendo en otros lugares
en el mundo porque en venezuela no
confiaban en los taxis sino me monto en
un taxi como me va a montar en el carro
de un extraño me decían y bueno
evidentemente después de escuchar esto
dije bueno claro debe ser que es verdad
debe ser que no se puede
regresé y empecé a trabajar en poses
meets que como coincidencia
es la aplicación de delivery más grande
de los ángeles y desde que empecé en
post mails y me empecé a desarrollar en
la empresa que terminé liderando todo el
equipo de adquisición de usuarios en
todo ese camino y sobre todo al
principio me di cuenta que el tema de la
confianza en un extraño existía incluso
en un país desarrollado
después de hablar con personas de otras
empresas similares me di cuenta que era
un problema de
todos los países no era un problema de
un país el tema es como tenemos estas
personas que son contratistas
independientes que realmente no son
empleados de la empresa que van a
interactuar con clientes como hacemos
que los uno que los clientes de verdad
confíen en el proceso y en el sistema
pero dos como nos aseguramos que de
verdad no pase nada y el hecho de que
eso era una conversación en países
desarrollados me hizo de verdad
cuestionar que quizás esto era
sencillamente naturaleza humana no
confiar y que simplemente hay que crear
procesos y sistemas que crean esa
confianza
también estando en pocos meses me di
cuenta de todo el valor que los
repartidores veían acá los repartidores
veían que podían tener un horario
flexible
podían conectarse cuando quisieran
desconectarse cuando quisieran podían no
tener un jefe o ser su propio jefe
efectivamente
conocí a estudiantes que lo utilizaban
para tener una base de ganancia para
poder concentrarse en sus estudios y no
estar preocupados conocí a artistas que
lo utilizaban para
y seguir sus sueños y hacer sus
proyectos teniendo una base financiera
suficiente conocí gente que no tenía
absolutamente nada y que utilizó esto
para salir de la situación en la que
estaban y eventualmente emprender e
incluso más allá de los repartidores vi
como los comercios que estaban asociados
a la plataforma
muchos de ellos pequeños quizás
comercios en una zona peligrosa un
camión de comida que no tenía los
permisos para operar en la mejor zona
ahora tenía acceso a cientos de miles de
clientes y los permitían crecer y no
solamente los permitían crecer sino que
interés indirectamente al crecer se
expandían y contrataban a más personas y
era este círculo de generación de valor
fue imposible para mí no empezar a
conectar los puntos y pensar por primera
vez por un segundo bien seriamente que
quizás esto se podía hacer en venezuela
y que lo podía hacer yo yo me empieza en
papel en el 2019 y empieza como una idea
realmente de convertirnos en el
marketplace más grande en venezuela
convertirnos en el mejor amigo del hogar
venezolano pero hoy vamos a comenzar con
delivery de comida porque el
comportamiento más grande ya existente y
era donde yo tenía más experiencia y
sentía que podíamos ejecutar de manera
más exitosa pero si eso funcionaba
eventualmente íbamos a entregar
supermercado farmacia íbamos a vender
entradas para eventos y vamos a crear el
primer sistema de wright servín en
venezuela y vamos a poder permitir
esencialmente que todo el mundo se
movilice o reciba lo que necesite cuando
lo necesite
y en esa idea decidí poner absolutamente
todos mis ahorros que no era demasiado
pero nos iba a dar más o menos dos meses
de oxígeno a la empresa para crear la
aplicación armar el equipo inicial que
de hecho se convirtieron en personas en
las que yo confiaba muchísimo personas
que conocí en el colegio inicialmente y
juntos armamos la marca la aplicación
estaba casi lista el modelo de negocios
estaba listo empezamos a hablar con
posibles repartidores posibles los
primeros 30 comercios que probablemente
iban a estar en la aplicación
y un día me llegó el back pack verde que
hoy vemos en la calle y al tenerlo en la
mano a pesar de que no habíamos
levantado todo el capital que
necesitábamos para todo el primer año
que era lo que queríamos hacer antes de
lanzar
yo dije 'te sabes que esto es tan
tangible ya vamos a poner una fecha de
lanzamiento
vamos a lanzar el 15 de abril pase lo
que pase
pero el camino de levantar capital no
fue sencillo y fue
todo lo contrario de lo que esperábamos
nos encontramos con inversionistas
grandes venezolanos que pensábamos
crearían creerían en el proyecto y nos
dieron que no
nos encontramos inversionistas
extranjeros que pensamos y les iba a
gustar el proyecto como parte de una
economía emergente y que dijeron todavía
no
y la razón del no era la misma razón por
la que mi familia me dijo que no podía
existir en el 2017
por la venezuela peligrosa
no podía existir porque había tanta
gente en un estado de supervivencia me
decían los inversionistas y claro cuando
hay tanta gente en un estado de
supervivencia estar en un estado de
supervivencia quita la autoestima porque
no estás recibiendo valor y claro hoy me
doy cuenta también y pensé en ese
momento cuando no estás recibiendo valor
quizás la única opción es extraer valor
al mismo tiempo yo seguía trabajando en
una empresa en san francisco porque
tenía que pagar la renta más aún después
de haber puesto todos mis ahorros en
esto
y empezaron las dudas quizás no debía
hacer esto quizás está una mala idea
pasaba el tiempo y bajaba la cantidad de
dinero que yo me tenía en la cuenta solo
teníamos dos meses y un día recuerdo me
encerré en el cuarto apague el teléfono
me desconecté y y empecé a pensar en
todo esto y está bien decaído la verdad
llegó mi esposa a la casa y me vio y
claramente supo que estaba pasando algo
y le expliqué que estaba pensando en
abandonar el proyecto
ella me sentó y me dijo no
tienes que renunciar a tu trabajo en san
francisco no hay o me tienes que
renunciar a tu trabajo no son francisco
mañana y yo sé que eres el que más está
ganando de los dos pero no importa si tú
estás cómodo comemos ramen los dos por
el tiempo que sea necesario pero si no
haces esto te vas a arrepentir y te vas
arrepentir porque nunca más
probablemente vas a tener una
oportunidad de
agarrar todo lo que has aprendido en tu
carrera y utilizarlo para crear tanto
valor en tu país natal y tanto valor
para tanta gente
y después de escuchar esto recordé a mi
primo y pensé en sí que qué pasaría si
él hubiera tenido yo mi en el 2017
cuando se quedó sin trabajo
quizás no hubiera estado triste cuando
habló conmigo quizás hubiera trabajado
en yo me hubiera arreglado su situación
y hubiera pensado en que hacer mucho más
rápido y quizás hubiera agregado aún más
valor a la sociedad de vuelta
y renuncie
y empezamos a trabajar en un proceso de
reclutamiento en el que pudiéramos
encontrar personas como mi primo
personas que no solamente querían
recibir valor y era lo que buscaban de
manera honesta sino que además
entendieran que el sistema de creación
de valor había que protegerlo y que
solamente podíamos dejar entrar a las
personas que se sintieran igual y en el
proceso de reclutamiento además de
filtrar evidentemente a las personas
basados en su historia previa
también creamos un proceso de tres a
cuatro días de entrenamiento en el cual
al final había un examen y mucha gente
piensa que el examen y la nota del
examen del examen era lo importante pero
la nota no era lo importante eran esos
tres o cuatro días en los cuales veíamos
quiénes eran y veíamos esa ambición y es
que era lo que querían extraer de la
plataforma y conseguimos a las personas
adecuadas para que efectivamente nunca
pasara nada o esa era la idea y lanzamos
con tres semanas en la cuenta
hicimos
nueve órdenes el primer día
y hasta hoy hemos hecho 900.000 órdenes
de comida supermercados farmacias
entregadas exitosamente
y hemos / hemos hecho 100.000 carreras
de johnny rights nuestro servicio de
raid schering de transporte para
movilizar a venezuela
remarcablemente pero también de manera
obvia hoy veo nunca ha pasado nada
nunca han robado un cliente
nunca alguien se ha montado en el carro
de un extraño y le ha pasado algo y
después de esas tres semanas iniciales
cuando estábamos a punto de quedarnos
sin dinero
terminamos quedando en white conviene
ser el acelerador de stavros más
importante del mundo de 14.000 empresas
que aplicaron quedaron 400 y nosotros
fuimos la única empresa venezolana que
logró quedar y eso nos dio la validación
que necesitábamos para que aquellos
inversionistas que en su momento dijeron
que no o dijeran que sí y que
inversionistas que ni sabíamos que
existían creyeran que esto era posible
de hecho todos los repartidores que han
hecho estas 900 mil órdenes han visto
tanto valor que han decidido dejar de
recibirlo por un momento y quiero que
vean este vídeo
en son dos commerce que decidieron
ayudar a una señora que estaba en el
medio de un diluvio universal se había
inundado una de las avenidas principales
de caracas por completo la señora estaba
atrapada con su carro no podía salir los
iones apagaron en el medio de la lluvia
sus teléfonos
cuando llueve hay mucha demanda
decidieron dejar de ganar para ayudar a
esa persona y eso es posible porque
están recibiendo valor y se sienten
valiosos y entienden el valor que pueden
crear ven las cosas diferentes hasta hoy
hemos creado 1500 trabajos para
repartidores nuestros yo merz y hemos
creado más de 600 trabajos para
conductores de johnny wright hemos
creado 300 trabajos en los departamentos
corporativos de johnny y más de 1400
comercios en toda venezuela hoy ven más
ventas porque yo me existe incluso
comercios pequeños que empezaron como
una cocina en una casa hoy tienen una
locación adicional en un centro
comercial en la capital
y comercios que empezaron en valencia
terminan no dándose a caracas para abrir
locaciones adicionales de la mano con
nosotros y todas esas locaciones
adicionales naturalmente crean nuevos
trabajos para los empleados de esas
locaciones hay un repartidor unió mer
que se llama jonathan que quería ser dj
o quiere ser dj y
después de tres meses de trabajar en yo
me logró tener el suficiente dinero para
poder ahorrar y comprarse todos los
equipos que necesitaba para ser dj y hoy
jonathan está persiguiendo ese sueño
mientras en paralelo sigue siendo yo mer
y sigue repartiendo comida en caracas
conocí también de un conductor de johnny
wright llamémoslo carlos con una
historia muy parecida que hemos
escuchado mucho en venezuela
alguien un ingeniero que sentía que no
estaba ganando suficiente para mantener
a su familia y que estaba en el proceso
de hacer los papeles para mojarse méjico
y su plan era muy simple irse con una
mano lante y un atrás y empezar a
trabajar en über y mover gente en ciudad
de méxico hasta lograr estabilizarse y
lo pensar en su siguiente paso en ese
momento pero carlos
encontró yo mi rights la segunda semana
que lanzamos yo a mi rights como
producto y se dio cuenta que podía ganar
lo mismo en yo me rights en caracas en
su ciudad natal de lo que pudo haber
ganado en mexico y decidió no irse al
final me doy cuenta que la única razón
por la que yo me debe existir y hoy
existe
es por todo el valor que circula en su
cadena de valor y es la misma razón por
la que cualquier empresa debe existir
cuando le agrega valor a una persona esa
persona se siente valiosa sube su
autoestima
intrínsecamente logra devolver valor
generar valor no tiene fórmula
lamentablemente pero es un camino
increíble
a los 4 millones de venezolanos que
están fuera como yo les digo que
creación de valor tampoco tiene
fronteras
y a todos los que escuchan les digo que
definitivamente vale la pena y me di
cuenta que quizás el valor de yo mí no
está ni siquiera en nuestro ecosistema
sino en que podamos inspirar a que
existan más yo mis y no me refiero a más
empresas de delivery y no me refiero
sólo a venezuela me refiero a empresas
que creen ecosistemas
ayudándose de la tecnología y que apoyan
a toda latinoamérica que apoyen a países
emergentes y que esas personas que hoy
están aprendiendo algo fuera lo puedan
regresar a su país y dar valor para
generar valor gracias